complex systems is a huge umbrella for a
lot of research what happens to a system
as it gets bigger in some sense does
that give you intuition on the scaling
of intelligence
well
that is a great question and um I think
you know one question you can ask is
like there's individual intelligence and
then there's collective intelligence
and how much of the intelligence that we
have individually is actually grounded
in a more collective intelligence you
know I there's many things that I don't
know like I don't understand quantum
mechanics or something but I know
somebody who does
and therefore I feel like it's
understood
and a lot of our intelligence I think is
sort of more social than we think
oh absolutely